[Applause]
that they just dancing we are back with
s and Jennifer Jer everybody it is our
official New York City premiere and we
have an audience full of some of the
most vital people in town the door men
and women of NYC give it up
yourself in honor of them and in honor
of Hoda it's time because her name's
awesome and it goes with this we are
going to play a game called Hoda the
[Applause]
door okay yeah there's more clever stuff
AR coming you're welcome um here to help
us play please give it up for another
woman with years of experience at
Rockefeller Center uh she is the host of
Celebrity Name That Tune on Fox Jane
Kowski
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody you there
you I mean you might for
outf
pretty cute wow thank you for being here
and your fabulous dress I'm going to
steal thank you you too explain the game
while we beat all right I first of all I
want to say welcome to New York I am so
happy to have you here Kelly we all are
and now I'm going to explain the game to
you I love playing games emotional or
otherwise that's fun okay we have two
teams the teams are Kelly and Seth
versus Hoda and Jenna and this game is
all about famous
doors so I will ask either one of you a
question about a door or show you a
photo of a door on the screen the first
team to hit their button and correctly
answer the question or identify the door
get it doormen gets a point okay the
winning team will earn a prize for the
doormen on their respective sides of the
audence
go got it we got it all right are we
ready I'm ready all right here we
go the first question question
is hidden within a wardrobe this door
LED Lion The Witch in the wardrobe yes
see it's I know Narnia no no l the W St
room I'm
so but there different books C Lewis I
read them all they're different books
they are a lion the wish Awards WR was
in the question the answer is
naria love you I feel like I'm getting
cheated in New York already
Welcome to New York Welcome to New
York dang it okay here we go my kids are
going to be so dis this next question
let's watch the screen okay the photo
will zoom out buzz in when you know what
creature lives behind this
door Kelly a
hobbit
h i I did not hear someone shout that
from the audience the great news is I
did and I thought they said rabbit so
I'm glad I not
[Laughter]
all right next question one to one well
done team you're welcome this door was a
f is that who is we Morrison wait y we
had it oh was no I apologize I guess
we're giving it to you cuz you said no
that's okay that's okay he got it all
right Seth got it okay thought about it
but I did get it all
right next question St Peter sits and
judges those walking into the next life
Heaven's Gate we will accept that
Heaven's Gate or the ply gate the ply G
yes well
done all right are we ready for the next
one ready all right take a look at the
screen again okay buzz in when you know
who had to enter this chamber and face a
magical Test Chamber of Secrets Harry
Potter
good good door that's a good door right
there a good that's a scary door you're
getting into heaven I'm getting into
Hogwarts it's great oh you're so
competitive I love it I love it it's one
of my favorite doors all right here we
go in a certain horror movie what actor
broke down a door with an acent
announced Johnny Was Here Jack nichelson
Jack Nel shiny that is correct oh I
didn't know if you to say the movie was
like like
shin the problem is come on we're ready
this is the elevator door in a famous
building in New York City buzzing when
you building Empire State Building yeah
yes so I just got here just got here I
didn't know that one oh oh okay that
sound means that we have to go to the
final question which will be worth three
points the score is four to three but
it's still anyone's game this one is
worth three points okay okay all right
this is another visual
clue when you can name the movie in
which this cold damp door was featured
buzz in and let see
it what is that Edward Scissor Hands no
sorry the Titanic
[Applause]
oh she looks like Edward Scissor Hands
this CLK okay um it doesn't matter
because it's my show and we're here in
New York and everyone in the audience is
getting this you may know our partners
the iconic food and drink wear brand
Stanley um and their Tik Tok famous
quencher the emotional support water
bottle it's lovely um all their products
are sustainable and reusable which is
awesome and the studio audience is going
to know that firsthand because you're
all getting a $250 gift card for
Stanley
yes thank you so much to Dame for toe
keeper hosting remember to watch her
show Celebrity Name That Tune Tuesday
nights on FX we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys yall have a great night
I'm going
home